ciao ragazzi allora questo video e di
una serietà come mai prima d'ora
avete visto il titolo e pensate anzi
date quasi per scontato che sia un click
bates e vi giuro con tutto me stesso
vorrei vorrei che questo fosse un click
bait della madonna ma vi giuro che non
lo è youtube potrebbe chiudere e non è
uno scherzo questa cosa cioè non ho per
niente esagerato entro fine anno verrà
deciso se approvare la legge numero 13
che cos'è questa legge numero 13 magari
ne avete sentito parlare ultimamente
deve venire approvata dal parlamento
europeo quindi solo in europa solo in
europa che se passa così come scritta
potrebbe e sottolineo potrebbe far
chiudere youtube prima di spiegarvi in
che cosa consiste vi dico come sono
venuto a conoscenza della legge numero
13 pranzato con alcuni esponenti di
youtube un paio di settimane fa e quindi
mi hanno chiesto di parlare di questa
cosa e dopo essermi documentato perché
vorrei fare costruito una volta sola non
vorrei farne un altro ho deciso di
esporre il problema questo allarme è
stato lanciato da pochissime ma
pochissime persone in italia l'unico
video che ho visto è stato quello di
willwoosh che è uscito qualche settimana
fa dove parla di questa cosa
dando per scontato che succederà che
youtube chiuda appunto ma non solo
youtube si tratta proprio di un problema
che affligge tutto il web non solo ma
adesso ci arriviamo questa cosa che dice
guglielmo è vera
l'unica cosa che guglielmo sbaglia e che
non è detto che succeda perché data non
è detto l'articolo 13 che potrebbe
venire approvato entro fine anno per dal
parlamento europeo dice che vi faccio
sempre un ri assoluto perché sono cose
super legali quindi non avrebbe senso
definirle parola prepara ora però il
riassunto dice che le piattaforme web
compreso youtube
se questa legge viene approvata devono
prendersi la piena responsabilità di
tutti i contenuti che i creatori
caricano a livello di copyright nel
senso che se io metto una canzone di
justin bieber di sottofondo mio video
ovviamente sto infrangendo un copyright
ora come ora se io faccio questa cosa
sono io il responsabile io fa vj omesso
la canzone
beaver quindi sono io ad avere delle
controversie con l'etichetta
discografica di justin bieber
se questa legge passa non sarò più io ad
avere questo problema ma sarà youtube e
da una parte uno dice figata così non è
più colpa mia d'altra parte siamo in
tanti quanti siamo in europa che
carichiamo video non mi riferisco agli
youtuber grandi saremo un migliaio di
youtuber grossi mi riferisco a tutti gli
youtubers siamo veramente tanti youtube
non può umanamente guardare ogni singolo
video che viene caricato sulla
piattaforma dall'inizio alla fine e
verificarne l'originalità l'algoritmo lo
fa per youtube è una cosa è una macchina
che si occupa di questo ogni volta che
ogni qual volta che viene caricato un
video viene analizzato se vengono viste
delle canzoni all'interno dei contenuti
visivi anche eco pil perché non sono
solo le canzoni completate anche i
contenuti visivi sono proprietati se c'è
un copyright
lo rileva se un copyright non riesce ad
essere rilevato se l'articolo 13 passa
quel video è incriminato e youtube si
prende la responsabilità di quel video
youtube mi ha già detto quando ho fatto
il pranzo che internamente stanno
discutendo di questa cosa
se l'articolo 13 passa youtube piuttosto
che prendersi le responsabilità che non
potrebbe prendersi di ogni singolo
youtuber potrebbe chiudere in tutta
europa spagna francia italia ovunque in
europa youtube potrebbe chiude potrebbe
chiudere non è detto
se l'articolo 13 passa così come per
youtube sarebbe un problema se
l'articolo 13 passa ma con delle
postille aggiuntive ad esempio a youtube
sarà consentito caricare la
responsabilità dei contenuti sui propri
creator
in quel caso non succederebbe niente io
sto parlando dell'estrema possibilità
che questa cosa possa succedere perché
non è detto che succeda ma potrebbe
succedere e youtube non potrebbe
prendersi questa responsabilità per
tutti quanti è umanamente impossibile
controllare ogni video vi ripeto non
parliamo solo di canzoni messe nei video
non parliamo solo di contenuti visivi
quindi tipo trailer di film
parliamo anche di cose stupide tipo la
locandina di un film o un meme che non
sei autorizzato a mettere perché magari
non l'hai fatto tu
parliamo di tantissime possibilità non
solo di canzoni di contenuti video
quindi umanamente impossibile
impossibile che youtube controlli tutto
quindi è normale che noi creator
dobbiamo prenderci singolarmente le
responsabilità dei nostri contenuti è
più che normale perché questa cosa non
sta facendo il boom perché è una cosa
grave quella di cui sto parlando ma
perché non se ne sente parlare per due
motivi il primo è una cosa veramente
apocalittica c'è nel senso è talmente
grave che è impossibile che succede
nella mente di una persona
la persona di youtube è troppo grosso e
impossibile che succeda perché è
un'azienda multimiliardaria non può
succedere questa cosa ed è una minchiata
incredibile può succedere non è che se
youtube è gigantesco vuol dire che gode
di diritti in più può succedere e quando
ho fatto il pranzo con youtube
erano tutti molto allarmati vi faccio un
esempio è passata una legge simile che
l'articolo 11 in spagna che ha abolito
google news che cos'è google news
quando voi scrivete su google notizie e
milano gli appaiono su google le
ricerche nei quotidiani più famosi no la
legge 11 in spagna è stata provata ed è
una legge contro non lo so nel dettaglio
comunque sia andava contro google news e
google news in spagna non esiste più
cioè se tu cerchi notizie e bla bla bla
non trovi più niente devi andare a
cercar tele proprio di persona o
comprando fisicamente il giornale o
andando all'interno del sito di tipo
dovesse entrare tu dentro repubblica
se google non può più dare notizie non è
che se un'azienda è gigantesca è immune
alle leggi non lo è per niente quindi
appellarsi alla grandezza di una
piattaforma è sbagliato youtube stessa è
preoccupata per questo e mi dice tutti
sono convinti che siano talmente grossi
che questa cosa non può succedere e
invece noi siamo preoccupatissimi può
succedere viene preso sottogamba perché
tutti dicono che può non succedere mai
non è vero la seconda cosa perché la
televisione comunque i mass media non ne
parlano perché il web è il più grande
competitor dei mass media di dei
giornali di
della televisione in primis anche perché
da quando esiste youtube le televisioni
soffrono di questa cosa perché il
pubblico ormai si è splittato di quelli
che guardano la televisione quelli che
guardano il qube quelli che guardano
entrambe le cose quindi se youtube è
fuori dai giochi a voi non vi rimane che
guardare la tv non potete guardare
nient'altro che quello quindi giova alla
televisione non parlarne di queste cose
quindi è normale che non ne sentirete
mai parlare in tv io stesso quando ho
sentito parlare di questa cosa ho detto
ma quando michael succedono una roba del
genere invece mi è stato ribadito più
volte da più fonti che in realtà anche
io faccio parte di quelli che prendevano
la cosa sotto gamba ma è data potrebbe
veramente succedere magari non succeda
niente ma non è per niente detto
potrebbe succedere e io sono qui oggi
per chiedervi aiuto in questo parto dal
presupposto che non sono solo io a farlo
ci sono un sacco di altri clienti
willwoosh l'ala fatto già appunto ci
sono tantissimi altri europei che stanno
prendendo parte a questo a questo
progetto che si chiama asta che save
your internet dove tutti quanti possiamo
fare la differenza c'è questa petizione
dove voi potete firmare attraverso il
web per schierarmi dalla parte del del
web punto per andare contro questa legge
youtube non può andare al parlamento
europeo e dire ciao siamo 10 milioni di
persone contro questa legge non fatela
non si può fare questo però se la
petizione a tantissime persone schierate
dalla loro parte possono andare a dire
ciao ragazzi
vedete tutte queste persone sono contro
non si può fare un qualche cosa per non
farla così drastica o meglio seguire
sempre quella che è la legge mal
tutelare comunque contenuti che ci sono
e vi faccio presente ancora una cosa non
è che quando approvano la legge da lì in
poi
noi non possiamo fare più video questa
cosa affligge tutti i video anche quelli
vecchi
c'è quindi youtube potrebbe proprio
essere oscurato in tutta europa quindi
anche tutti i video vecchi di tutti noi
youtubers europei potrebbero scomparire
quindi voi non avreste più youtube zero
se non i contenuti originali quindi tipo
netflix dovreste pagare youtube premium
per vedere i contenuti originali che
sono quelli approvati internamente da
youtube che sono quelli a pagamento tipo
non so se non conoscete tipo scar più di
pai che la serie che vip aveva fatto
premetto che sono comunque lo 0 0 0 0 1
per cento di tutti i video che ci sono
su youtube non solo su youtube
ovviamente oggi parlo da youtube e
quindi parlo per youtube per
semplificarvi la cosa è una cosa che va
ad affliggere tutto il web in europa
quindi dailymotion facebook instagram
tutti i siti che dove tu utente puoi
pubblicare un qualche cosa di tuo
tutti questi siti si devono prendere la
responsabilità di ciò che pubblicano i
loro utenti
e questa una cosa che difficilmente una
piattaforma può prendersi in carico
quindi ci tengo a ribadire per
l'ennesima volta che io sto parlando
dell'estrema possibilità che possa
succedere perché magari anche senza la
petizione si arriva al momento di
approvare quella legge vengono definite
varie cose perché magari la legge ed è
lunga come la bibbia e quindi in mezzo
ci sono delle postille che salvaguardano
youtube facebook
insomma i vari siti ma noi non possiamo
saperlo e per non saperlo che il mare
questa petizione che io ovviamente ho
già firmato può aiutarci tutti quanti la
mia più grande paura prima di fare
questo video era quella di creare una
possibile disinformazione quindi io mi
sono documentato parlando con youtube
parlando col mio network leggendo gli
articoli guardando i video
ho guardato un sacco di cose prima di
fare questo video qui magari la sto
facendo più grossa di quanto realmente
però non voglio creare un terrorismo
psicologico sul web di questa cosa
succederà perché come ho detto potrebbe
non succedere niente ma potrebbe anche
succedere quindi laddove una firma può
fare la differenza e non vedo nessun
problema nel provare a risolvere la
situazione tanto non costa niente farlo
vi lascio il link quindi qui sotto in
descrizione per firmare la petizione
vi lascio l'ashtag i vari video se
volete approfondire il discorso
spero che questo video non vado a creare
allarmismi o polemiche perché non è
questa la mia intenzione quindi agazzi
spero avete capito il discorso e niente
io concludo quel video
non faccio la mia altro solita perché un
video diverso così come non ho fatto la
intro e niente ciao